As an example of a mean-variance
calculation, we
will now consider the continuous
uniform random
variable which we have
introduced a little earlier.
This is the continuous analog
of the discrete uniform, for
which we have already seen
formulas for the corresponding
mean and variance.
So let us now calculate the mean
or expected value for the
continuous case.
The mean is defined as an
integral that ranges over the
entire real line.
On the other hand, we recognize
that the density is
equal to 0 outside the interval
from a to b, and
therefore, there is going to
be no contribution to the
integral from those x's
outside that interval.
This means that we can integrate
just over the
interval from a to b.
And inside that interval, the
value of the density is 1
over b minus a.
We can carry out this
integration and find an answer
equal to a plus b over 2, which,
interestingly, also
happens to be the same as
in the discrete case.
In fact, we could find this
answer without having to run
this integration.
We could just recognize that
this PDF is symmetric around
the midpoint of the interval,
and the midpoint is
a plus b over 2.
We now continue with what is
involved in the calculation of
the expected value of the square
of the random variable.
Using the expected value rule,
this is the integral of x
squared times the density, but
because of the same argument
as before, we only need to
integrate from a to b.
We can evaluate this integral,
and the answer turns out to be
1 over (b minus a) times
(b cube over 3
minus a cube over 3).
The reason why these cubic
terms appear is that the
integral of the x square
function is x
cube divided by 3.
Now that we have this quantity
available, we're ready to
calculate the variance using
this alternative formula,
which, as we have often
discussed, usually provides us
a quicker way to carry
out the calculation.
We take this term,
insert it here.
We take the square of this
term, insert it here.
Carry out some algebra, and
eventually we find an answer
which is equal to b minus
a squared over 12.
And this is the formula for
the variance of a uniform
random variable.
We can take the square root of
this expression to find the
standard deviation, and the
standard deviation is going to
be b minus a divided by
the square root of 12.
A few observations.
First, the formula looks quite
similar to the formula for the
variance that we had in the
discrete case, except that in
the discrete case, we
have this extra
additive factor of 2.
More interestingly, and perhaps
more important, is
that the standard deviation is
proportional to the width of
this uniform.
The wider it is, the
larger the standard
deviation will be.
And this conforms to our
intuition that the standard
deviation captures the width of
a particular distribution.
And the variance, of course,
becomes larger when
the width is larger.
And as far as the variance is
concerned, it increases with
the square of the length of
the interval over which we
have our distribution.